et comme chaque lundi nous retrouvons la
chronique culturelle de sephora namani
bonsoir à sephora bonsoir floral alors
c'est sûr je vous présente le portrait
d'un artiste et vous laisse deviner de
qui il s'agit messieurs les puits mafia
deep lui docteur l'ebit a mis à chanter
je suis l'un gynécologue de votre femme
l émotion
mondiale
ça
m est magnifique mais les regarde
je mets punu
mon petit chêne orouba mon gros cul quoi
mon gros cul ma raie naissance
bien sûr c'est pour elle c'était facile
de nexans et des sous-titrés il s'agit
du comédien et humoriste françois xavier
demaison très célèbre depuis son rôle
dans le film d'antoine de caunes coluche
l'histoire d'un mec qui est sorti en
2008 tout à fait donc là ce que vous
venez de voir c'est un extrait de son
deuxième spectacle demaison s'évade et
qui a fait un triomphe et vendredi
dernier xavier demaison était à andrésy
pour présenter son tout nouveau
spectacle demaison road il nous en parle
j'ai l'impression que ces spectacles
plus personnel des trois le plus
efficace les 3 donc je suis vraiment
très heureux de jouer à chaque fois
c'est un bonheur c'est une tournée
magique quoi les gens sont debout c'est
la folie ça se passe on rit beaucoup il
ya beaucoup d'interactivité avec le
public et les moments de théâtre et des
moments vraiment où je joue avec le
public
il ya des moments où avec dimanche me
raconte sous forme de stand up c'est ses
empreintes à tous ces styles alors un
spectacle multiples avec plus de
stand-up que dans les autres et puis
toujours des sketches avec une galerie
de personnages pour évoquer différents
thèmes tels que la politique l'écologie
pour interpeller le public est toujours
ce souci de faire réfléchir par le rire
alors nous n'avons pas pu avoir d'image
de ce tout nouveau spectacle car il a à
peine trente représentations depuis sa
sortie de résidence en janvier dernier
et la production ne souhaite pas encore
diffusé des images c'est encore un
spectacle top secret alors à cette
soirée était associé le rire médecin une
association parrainée par françois
xavier demaison depuis 2009 qui fait
intervenir des clowns professionnels
dont les services pédiatriques des
hôpitaux
cette cause me touche tout ce qui touche
à l'enfance me toucher une petite fille
et puis je trouve ça magnifique ses
clones qui vont dans les hôpitaux
divertir les les enfants les faire
oublier qu'ils sont hospitalisés
et puis danser rires d'enfants il ya
aussi une manière pour l'enfant de
montres à ses parents que c'est toujours
un enfant que
derrière la maladie à tout va bien quoi
alors deux maisons rodez donc son
troisième spectacle françois xavier
demaison a commencé d'ailleurs
relativement tard la comédie il me
semble oui tout à fait alors avec deux
parents avocat il s'est tourné plus ou
moins logiquement vers des études
juridiques et de science politique après
un bac littéraire tout en menant de
front quand même des études de comédie
car il avait la classe libre du cours
florent qui est considéré comme étant la
la classe le plus difficile et puis il
entame donc une carrière en 1998 comme
auditeur dans la fiscalité
internationale jusqu'à ce tragique jour
de 11 septembre 2001 jour où il décide
de changer de vie je crois que
profondément je m'ennuyais là où j'étais
je faisais de la fiscalité
internationale à paris aux états unis
et je crois que ma place était sur scène
que je m'étais
j'avais réfréner cette passion
puisqu'elle a ressurgi un jour de 11
septembre où je me suis dit que la vie
était courte que le monde était fou
qu'il fallait être plus fou que lui et
que je voulais plus perdre ma vie à la
gagner alors sephora quels seront les
prochains rendez vous on pourra espérer
voir le spectacle de xavier françois
xavier demaison alors le spectacle va
bien sûr poursuivre sa tournée dans
toute la france dix dates en janvier
2007 à l'olympia tout de même et c'est
une grosse année pour l'artiste car en
septembre prochain sortira en salles son
film comment j'ai rencontré mon père
film de maximo motte avec isabelle carré
en décembre également vous pourrez le
retrouver en salle pour les têtes de
l'emploi un film d'alexandre charlot aux
côtés de franck dubosc et elsa
zylberstein mais avant cela très
prochainement le 22 juin précisément
vous pourrez le retrouver dans un film
de christophe barratier sur l' affaire
kerviel dont l'outsider
entré à la société générale c'est
rejoindre les meilleurs parmi les
meilleurs moyens nouveaux traders kyle
king esprit d'équipé avec une dernière
recommandation sortez des sentiers
battus
une noisette la c1 millions d'euros
imagine qu'on me demande de gagner 5 sur
l'année chaque trader si stratégie tout
ce que tu as gagné en plus grande au
sein car les merlus ont tenté sur ton
truc anna se cabre merci beaucoup
sephora plus d'informations sur la
programmation de l'artiste à l'adresse
qui s'affiche en bandeau en bas de votre
écran